la música invadió anoche la alfombra
roja de este festival de cannes porque
muy tarde se presentó the velvet
underground una película del director
estadounidense todd haynes un documental
sobre este mítico grupo de los años 60
en nueva york' un filme que tiene muchas
imágenes inéditas pero que sobre todo se
centra en la relación talentosa pero
también de hermanos enemigos entre jon
kyl y lou reed
recordemos que el director ya tiene
varias películas relacionadas con la
música concretamente destacamos a himno
de ar dedicada a bob dylan que se
presentó en el año 2006 sino hoy la
competencia internacional sigue con dos
nuevas películas
julie una película noruega pero sobre
todo con lin hui la única película
africana de las 24 seleccionadas de la
competencia oficial es una película del
chat que cuenta la historia de una madre
que tiene una hija adolescente que queda
embarazada pero que quiere abortar todo
un conflicto en un país de mayoría
musulmana